in the uncharted movie gamers have a lot
to recognize nathan drake meets nathan
drake again sully gets his mustache
eventually
the first shot of uncharted is a fade in
on tom holland's nathan drake dangling
upside down from a cargo container
flapping out of the back of an in-flight
airplane it's a bold way to kick off the
movie and also a reference to two
different games at the same time the
shot itself which shows nate trying to
get his bearings in the middle of a
dangerous situation after briefly
blacking out harkens back to the first
scene of uncharted 2 among thieves in
which nate wakes up in a wrecked train
car hanging off the side of a cliff in
both cases the action scene shown at the
start ends up being a flash forward set
in the middle of the actual story that's
a fun nod in itself but the uncharted
movie twists the reference by placing it
in a cargo plane an allusion to a
totally different action sequence from
uncharted 3 drake's deception
every debonair action hero has to have
at least one recognizable catchphrase
and in the case of nathan drake it's
just two
oh
words
well simple this brief expletive is
uttered time and time again by nate
throughout the uncharted games ancient
machinery breaking down and falling on
top of you crap just got double crossed
by your partner crap need something to
shout dramatically as you leap from one
crumbling ledge to another crap the
phrase is just endlessly versatile
holland's version of drake gets to utter
the character's signature cry a couple
of different times in the uncharted film
and while it might just seem like a
throwaway line to those who haven't
played the games it's a fun little
easter egg for those who have
nathan drake's origin story is eeked out
slowly over the four mainline uncharted
games with many details not revealed
until the events of uncharted 4 a
thief's end a lot of those details show
up in the movie as well albeit with a
few changes as in the games after a
family tragedy nate and sam end up
living in a catholic orphanage in boston
named for saint francis sam the older
brother ends up departing the orphanage
before nate is old enough leaving him
with a few mementos to remember him by
the first item sam gives nate is an old
ring with the latin inscription
cycparvus magna which translates to
greatness from small beginnings this is
nate's most treasured keepsake in the
video games though in the original
version of the story he steals it from a
museum rather than getting it from sam
the movie's biggest blink and you'll
miss it easter egg comes relatively
early on after sully first propositions
nate to help him find the lost treasure
of ferdinand magellan back at his own
place nate digs through a trunk full of
mementos to find some old postcards from
his brother and as he lifts the lid one
of the faded stickers briefly spotted by
the camera is revealed to be the naughty
dog logo the acclaimed game studio
responsible for creating uncharted
coincidentally one of naughty dog's
other big gaming franchises the last of
us is being adapted for a tv series at
hbo starring pedro pascal and bella
ramsay given the cinematic nature of the
developers games we might be seeing the
naughty dog logo in live action a lot
more going forward
as proven by the opening cargo plane
scene uncharted has no qualms about
ripping entire sequences and story beats
out of the video games nate and sully's
auction heist is another example of that
in uncharted 4 nate sully and sam all
sneak into a secret black market auction
in italy to steal you guessed it an old
cross that's actually the key to a lost
treasure the movie moves the auction to
new york city and ties its cross to
magellan but the core beats are still
incredibly similar
that's it up here
so we just have to climb up there and
kill the lights grab the cross in the
dark
specifically the actual bidding scene is
basically pulled straight out of
uncharted 4. in the game nate goes
gallivanting all over the estate trying
to figure out how to cut the power his
delays forced sully to bid against the
game's main villain rave adler to buy
them time
during the whole scene rafe is
accompanied by nadine ross the leader of
a mercenary team who serves as his main
muscle throughout the game the dynamic
between rafe and nadine is strikingly
similar to that between antonio
banderas's santiago mancada and tati
gabriel's joe braddock in the movie all
the boomer also present and bid against
sully while holland drake tries to turn
off the lights even the red tuxedo
jacket sully steals from a waiter in the
movie scene is pulled straight from
uncharted 4 though sam is the one to
wear it there
uncharted pays tribute to the
franchise's hollywood inspiration a few
different times in barcelona for
instance nate takes sully and chloe to
an old church where he believes
magellan's gold to be buried when they
enter the building however nate is
shaken by the sight of a nun inside
flashing him back to some less than
happy memories of his childhood it's
then that he drops the line nuns why
does that always have to be nuns which
is clearly a reference to harrison
ford's famous line from raiders of the
lost ark
snakes
why did it have to be snakes
shortly thereafter in an attempt to bond
with chloe nate asks her why she decided
to become indiana jones this is
obviously less of an easter egg and more
of an overt reference that nearly breaks
the fourth wall the revelation that
indiana jones exists in the uncharted
universe is funny and maybe even a
little odd but you've got to give the
movie credit for not trying to hide the
series's influences
well before the theatrical release of
uncharted nolan north the man
responsible for nathan drake's voice and
performance capture in the video games
shared a picture of himself on set
chatting with tom holland the pick
immediately sparked speculation that
north could have a cameo in the film
which ultimately ended up being true
those in the know will recognize him as
the tourists lounging on the beach in
the philippines who remarks to nate and
chloe that he too fell out of a plane
once obviously that line is referencing
the events of uncharted 3. it's fun to
see the two versions of drake interact
and if anything the film maybe could
have benefited from a little more nolan
north as a fun bonus norse cameo is
accompanied by a quiet reprise of the
uncharted games theme music
after nearly two hours of searching
across the globe nate finally finds
magellan's lost gold aboard two pirate
ships hidden in a cave that particular
setting is essentially the same as the
final act of uncharted 4 when nate and
his wife elena discover henry avery's
lost ship hiding in a watery cavern on
turtle island in both cases the ships
are loaded down with treasure troves of
gold and they both end up eluding nate's
grass albeit in different ways in the
game every ship gets set on fire and
quickly burns to ashes with the cave
itself collapsing on top of it nate and
rafe battle with pirate swords as the
ship implodes with her hero just barely
making it out alive in the movie bryda
calls the two ships out of the cave
suspended from helicopters leading to an
airborne battle in which nate once again
employs the use of a rusty old sword
though most of the treasure gets
properly claimed by the government of
the philippines afterwards nate and
sully do get out with a bit of gold for
themselves a small victory that harkens
back to a similar outcome in the first
uncharted game
like cartoon characters video game
characters tend to wear the same outfits
a lot as such most famous characters
like nathan drake and the rest of the
uncharted gang have pretty memorable
looks and many of those are represented
in the movie in one form or another
holland's version of nate sports several
different outfits throughout the film
and in the final battle aboard the
flying ships he assembles a pretty
spot-on replica of the character's game
look khaki cargo pants a dull white
henley shirt with the sleeves pushed up
a brown shoulder holster for his handgun
and of course sir francis drake's ring
on a string around his neck the outfit
is very accurate to the games and it's a
fun way to represent nate fully becoming
the treasure hunter fans know him as
later on in the film's final post credit
scene nate also wears a white and red
baseball shirt another one of his
classic looks from the games
and he isn't the only one to get some
easter egg costumes either when chloe
first enters the story of barcelona
she's wearing a red outfit that's very
reminiscent of her look from uncharted
2. but you know my brother sam what else
aren't you telling me
for most of uncharted sam drake is
merely a spectre a missing man presumed
to be dead however in a scene tagged
onto the end of the movie it's revealed
that he's actually alive wasting away in
a foreign prison while the exact details
of sam's disappearance apparent death
and imprisonment are altered a bit for
the big screen this is pretty much
exactly what happens to the character in
the video games uncharted 4 shows how
sam and nate sneak into a panamanian
prison to get a vital clue to a big
treasure only to be betrayed and forced
to flee in the escape attempt sam is
shot and nate leaves him believing him
dead years later it's revealed that sam
survived the bullet and that he was
thrown in a dark cell to rot if an
uncharted 2 ever happens at sony
pictures it should be interesting to see
how the revelation of sam's survival
will work its way into the plot he may
have a bone or two to pick with wahlberg
sully for leaving him behind on the
request for magellan's treasure which
could cause some interesting tension
the movie's post-credit scene shows nate
negotiating with an eyepatch-wearing man
named gage played by game of thrones
alum pilo azbek the two have agreed on a
trade of nate's ring for an old nazi map
but gage quickly pulls a double cross
and demands both the most interesting
part of the scene for fans of the games
is that gage's boss is apparently named
roman a character named gabriel roman an
old acquaintance of sully's is one of
the main villains of the first uncharted
game there's no way that's a coincidence
which means that roman is being set up
as an antagonist for the next movie if
one gets made additionally the mention
of a nazi map is also a reference to the
first game in the series which involved
a cursed treasure sought by the nazis
during world war ii perhaps the most
exciting implication of these references
is that they paved the way for the
live-action debut of elena fisher nate's
constant companion and eventual life
partner in the games in the canon of the
games nate and elena meet at the
beginning of uncharted drake's fortune
and it's hard to imagine another movie
being produced without elena being a
part of it
should have seen that one coming
the uncharted post credit scene also
includes three fun easter eggs for sully
his mustache his revolver and a cigar
all three of those items are key parts
of sully's video game persona and they
are glaringly absent for most of the
film he's even wearing green in the shot
which is arguably his most frequently
worn color throughout the franchise it's
fun to see wahlberg's version of sully
finally completed with all the necessary
accessories but the scene also raises
the question why did it take him so long
to get them check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and tv
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you